of his single
we built this city we built this city on
sausage this city come on babe we built
this city
[Music]
but lyrics ratico my
[Music]
and I'm delighted to say the lab baby
blogger Marc coil joins me now in the
studio and Marc he mouthed at me as we
were listening to that so cringy choose
to do it yeah I think it's brilliant
yeah it's amazing I don't think there's
any bigger pop career lined up yeah it's
been a lot of fun and hopefully we've
done it for a good cause so you know
that's the main thing yeah tell me about
that so um how'd it all come about
because it certainly made people smile
and it's all going to a good cause as
you say tell us about that
yeah I guess our channel channel
generally is you know about making
people smile and make people laugh
because you know there's not always that
much enjoyment going on in the world and
this always came about from a tweet
somebody tweeted me about six months ago
saying that I should release this song I
downloaded the original song we built
this city played it to my little boy he
he went wild dancing around the living
room and I thought if he's up for it why
aren't I so sort of snowballed from
there he came up with a sausage roll
idea because it is very funny that was a
game that was from the tweet my passion
for sausage rolls has been a
long-running theme on my blog so it's
sort of it was the natural choice now
this is obviously going to help families
in poverty which unfortunately something
that is becoming more and more prevalent
this is something that's quite close to
your heart isn't it it is yeah you know
a couple years ago when we first had our
boy we did struggle for a long while we
got very close to having to need to use
some of the food banks in the UK and my
wife's mum actually volunteers it one of
the tresor trust food banks so we know
the importance of it here in the UK and
you know is the obvious choice when
singing about food as well and it being
Christmas it was a no-brainer for us
obviously as you say you've had tough
times in the past potentially needing to
use food banks yourself you set up this
blog lad baby two years ago when your
son was born did you ever have any idea
it was gonna be a successful if it is I
had no idea I say up to make a few mates
online that was all it was to make make
a few dads that were sort of going
through a similar life experience and
now it seems to be taking go from
strength to strength I want celebrity
dad of the year this year
it's amazing and if I can keep people
laughing that's that's the main thing
tell me about the community that you've
created around your blog three million
followers on Facebook now tell me about
it it's how it affects you people stop
you and talk to you people do stop stop
me they stop and have selfies and they
just want to chat it really is it's
amazing you know the people that follow
our blog are just so supportive of
pretty much everything we do and and we
try and give back to them however we can
so nice it's exciting we absolutely love
doing it and hopefully there's lots more
to come and of course we've got the very
pressing issue of there the countdown to
the Christmas number one spot now the UK
public have love backing an outside
their the NHS charity single was
publicly backed by Justin Bieber in 2016
are you hoping for the same from Ariana
I would love it I haven't had any
celebrity following or endorsements or
nothing nobody's come forward and done
it so if she wants to get behind it I'd
love it I'll send her some sausage rolls
if she wants but yeah a lot less fingers
crossed we're nearly there
I do wonder if Ariana's had a had a
taste of a UK sausage roll what's your
message for her if she's watching let me
know you address I'll send you some and
me I guess yeah I don't know I don't
know if she'll even know what one is but
let's hope so well there are a lot of
people out there who do and who will no
doubt be singing and eating sausage
rolls this Christmas thanks to you
thanks very much indeed for mark we're
coming in good luck with that